[Music]
look the only way you can change the
world is with
stories people really want to know what
it feels like to be a
photographer right shoulder down there
we go obviously there's a risk involved
it's this ying-yang of
danger and this incredible raw
Beauty that's its first breath that's so
cool Every Creature comes from somewhere
and yet when you see it with your own
eyes you can't help but feel sense of
magic I want to change stereotypes to
make an actual difference in people's
life I always was interested in things
unseen I'm que I'm black I'm religious i
p from iconography Fe that I in haveit I
just want to be the change we're on this
mission to chase big oil out of the
Bahamas just using our
cameras photographing out in the
elements you are at the mercy of Mother
Nature it was
just like a lightning
bolt when I'm shooting I'm in my element
beautiful here we go there's a
masterpiece everywhere it's not just
razzled Dazzle
Adventure
life all right this is it let's go these
moments that you
immortalize makes a lot of difference
okay you ready
we this is the adventure of a
lifetime just imagine how much more is
out
there
[Music]